but this is important breaking news
check this out Vice media nears deal for
400 million dollars sale out of
bankruptcy
Fortress investment and Soros fund
management come on here's the here's
here's the funniest thing about this
right it's the deal gives them a
valuation around 400 million a major
drop from 5.7 billion here's the other
thing though the evaluation includes the
existing debt that it has how much the
debt I believe there was a 250 million
dollar debt financing around a few years
ago and then a 30 million I'm not
exactly sure how they're how they're
doing it the 250 million in debt was
from Soros I think that was Soros fund
management as well
so it may be that source is actually
just buying the company for what would
that give them 120 million dollars no no
220 million dollars
from a company that was once once worth
5.7 billion so of the 400 million
they're paying out 220 of it was debt so
Soros already has 250 million in debt
with Vice so if the deal is for 400
million which includes the debt I could
be wrong about this maybe Bill and check
could could clarify If someone knows how
the economics works of it but it sounds
like Soros already holds a portion of
that 400 million unless the deal is to
buy out the rest of it but then he holds
the debt so I think this multi-billion
dollar company is being washed out for a
couple hundred million the whole click
bait apparatus is dying people are sick
of it buzzfeed's gone and it's only
being upheld by political actors like
but but Vice wasn't that in the
beginning
Vice got big because they were like
we're gonna go down and we're gonna hunt
down Scopolamine yeah dude
the magic Shaman who's gonna do crazy
like Ayahuasca and then it turned into
10 reasons SpongeBob's homophobic what
happened do you remember how do you know
how it changed exactly was there a
linchpin that switched or was it just a
slow burn Tim left I was told that was
it I was going I was I was there when
they were doing the based so so actually
Vice news started because of me and that
is the words of Shane Smith he said at
the night Foundation Awards they were
doing on the ground reporting but it was
not there was no news division they were
doing these like Adventure style
documentary shows where it's about the
regular guy going to Afghanistan and
telling a story and then I I was like I
want to do real news reporting what
changed simply is
in from my perspective I agree with this
take but this came from a friend of mine
who is who is a high level employee
they got accused of sexual harassment
and assault
and to get out of it the investors were
like become a feminist company that way
you can get past the negative press the
concern was it like we're not going to
go down and see our hundreds of millions
of dollars in investment lost
so just come out start doing feminist
stuff and you'll be safe from these
attacks and they went you got it
talk about a fall from grace if they
went the route I explained in my vision
they would be worth still billions of
dollars I told them to go the route that
we are going here yeah maybe they would
be worth like 900 million or 1.3 billion
like a quarter of what they ended up at
what they were at one point but they'd
still be around no I don't believe any
of what you guys are saying you think
I'm a liar I think both of you I think
what happened was Tim told them Tim saw
what the future was and he said you know
what you guys should do you should
Pander to feminists and the left the
young people love it you're going to get
a lot of viewership it's what the
mainstream media is doing let's imitate
the big guys because you wanted to leave
and start your own thing and then you
did I went and worked for Disney you
neutered them you wanted a little more
experience before you got out you know
and did your own thing you were you
played the long con the same thing
happened with fusion and it was
hilarious when I went to Fusion which is
ABC News Univision they said we want to
be nice Vice we want to be young and
edgy but we don't want to do the weird
stuff where they like crap in jugs and
like throw it in the air or something
like that because Vice did like weird
stuff like that and then I was like cool
and they said we want to do a show
that's very much travel Adventure
meeting like drug dealers in Venezuela
and covering those stories and I'm like
perfect let's make it happen and then
eight months later they brought in a new
editor-in-chief who changed his Twitter
Banner to down with whiteness and then I
was like oh boy and then I was just like
I was like here's what here's my plan
for this November I'm gonna go to
Fukushima on the anniversary or or you
know and see where they're at with the
like the re the Redevelopment of the
region and then they were like okay
that's cool I guess it gets half a
million views over the weekend and then
they're like but we're still really
interested in talking about trans kids
which gets like a thousand views they
were obsessed with chasing the stuff
sure enough a couple years later they
lay off everybody and they washed
billions down the toilet did Shane leave
the company at some point no he's still
there so he's getting this he's not the
CEO anymore and they're saying they're
gonna find a role for him but like this
guy's just not worth anything anymore
more I mean look don't get me wrong the
dude's probably worth you know I don't
know what this puts puts him at maybe
um Shane Smith yeah that'll put him at
maybe 80 million which is like like come
on it's not nothing he's a rich guy but
to have been a billionaire like their
media reporting you're worth 2 billion
or whatever and now it's just like you
know I don't think they're complete
idiots for marketing to the woke crowd
like I do think there is a large I'm not
on some copium or I think the majority
of the population are conservatives I've
I'm from Canada so I'm like okay there
are actually a lot of woke people out
there but it's just very hard to sell
wokeness through a corporation
through these like they can see the even
even the very silly kind of brainwashed
people they're like okay this is
clickbait this is a corporation that
makes millions of dollars telling me
about how we need to support trans
impoverished individuals doing ketamine
like that they can see the absurdity
itself it's okay I don't know though
there is there is a craving in general
for more genuine I think that's why live
streaming has become more a bigger thing
in general even the left-wing live
streamers on Twitch and stuff uh people
are just getting real tired of the
highly curated actual
um full-on propaganda it's just like the
Internet is just full-on MK Ultra yeah
all corporations are not people and when
they say stuff like Disney says that
something no no Disney isn't a thing
that can speak Disney's just a facade a
piece a paper that you tear away to see
who was it that said that yeah like if
you want to make the argument that
corporations are people then I'd love to
see some of these corporations go to
prison so when
so yes so when like a big pharmaceutical
company for instance is accused of fraud
we don't simply Go pass a fine we say we
are going to incarcerate your
corporation for five years meaning it
cannot operate everybody who works there
you no longer work there come back in
five years and let's see where you're at
and they go well we couldn't do that it
would be bad for the economy we'll tell
that to the guy who went to prison for
five years what's he supposed to do when
he gets out sorry I don't play that if
you've got a corporation and there are
people breaking the law within it and
it's widespread and the whole company
does it shut it down or even like 30 for
the death penalty in that case too oh
like the execution of the corporations
over the company Erasure of the machine
yeah I think that if you sell a company
you guys should change the name that's
that's I think unethical to call it
something else because a company is
amazing though but it's the company is
the people that are in the company that
is what it is it's a company of people
and so if the people change then it's a
different company so yeah but I mean
look I don't want the factory I just
want the name Callahan it's premium then
have it in parentheses behind the new
name at least so you see the trail of
like what it used to be what Disney now
is but it's not Disney Walt Disney's
gone that's going to make for very long
domain names yeah and and the
corporation owns a bunch of Ip so uh
you're talking about branding like a
Rebrand if they want it's like black
water they just reappear right something
new every other year
the idea that you could go to a say a
major pharmaceutical like let's say
there's a major pharmaceutical that was
accused of Fraud and then found to be
liable for that fraud and we're fined
billions I can't think of anything
like that I'm pretty sure it's all of
them every single one like we just it's
a cost of doing business so now you have
these big Pharmaceuticals being like
okay how much money can we make off
defrauding people 2 billion what will we
find by the government 1 billion hot dog
we're gonna make a million a billion
dollars that's what they do there needs
to be a more serious policy does anyone
have the schizophrenic soap Bonners soap
where it's got like all oh yes that
spies on you why is it schizo no it's
it's got like so much text about like
religion and God and you just sit there
and read it it's the one true religion
the Dr Bonner broners anyways
well no it's yeah
anyways my point is they should have
that on um any sort of pharmaceutical
company's bottle but it's like all of
their lawsuits no it's just listed all
over it and that should be their
punishment you have to list all it's
sort of available if you buy a pack of
cigarettes it has like a limp dick on it
or something right it's kind of like
that especially for the black lung the
last decade of lawsuits yeah how much
money they lost after time yeah you know
what you know what I think would
actually be even better than that for
political campaigns at the end of a
political ad in the same way that
pharmaceutical ads have to list side
effects they have to list every Scandal
that politician is involved in and like
every policy failure yeah it's Christian
yeah yeah and every stock like all of it
that was an extremely based bill of Matt
Gates and AOC to support oh yeah it was
Wild Bill against insider trading I love
seeing that I love seeing the far left
and the far right come together to own
politicians you know I do appreciate it
you know what the bills is insane and
wrong and yeah she's not wrong on this
but she's not wrong on this don't you
dare attack my queen
your queen your favorite is true behind
the scenes this is behind the scenes
Lauren gush is about AOC non-stop it's
called the restoring faith and
Government Act I like the name restoring
my faith in AOC act yeah I think you're
onto something with AOC like it's it's
not I cannot demonize it exactly like if
you really think she's Lex Luthor has
that kind of power to become Lex Luthor
we should engage in conversation now and
get ahead of this and rather than just
wait for some horrible populist Uprising
where we use the mob to dictate Law and
Order I think we need to psychologically
manipulate her by whenever she does
anything like really good super red pill
right wing need to just send her like
super loving messages constantly and
just be like keep going Queen keep going
and then she'll slowly like
psychologically be like oh well I'm
getting a lot of support for this and
just move further and further right and
then until I've fixed her and then
everyone's Gonna Keep criticizing her
from the right when she does something
bad and then it's just going to be
psychological abuse no it's gonna be
like very brutal both but both ways it's
gonna be like insanely High Praise and
then really brutal criticism
for is is Hardcore manipulation right
now but like this is a narcissistic
cycle
it has to be like we love you so much
but I can't believe you've failed us
here we're really disappointed but we
believe in you oh my gosh wouldn't it be
awesome if political commentary was done
that way thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time